des trous dans la chaussée remblayées à
la hâte c'est la seule trace du passage
de Wagner à krasnoïer le village le plus
au nord atteint samedi par les
mercenaires à moins de 400 km de Moscou
ils ont passé la nuit ici à la
station-service ils se sont mis en ligne
pour se ravitailler leur colonne s'est
formée dans cette direction sur environ
500 mètres de long
une arrivée soudaine d'hommes armées qui
ne semble pas avoir perturbé les
habitants mini tu m'envoi ils n'ont rien
dérangé ils se sont tenus calmement sur
le trottoir et ils n'ont abordé ni
parler à personne
après le coup de force avortée de leur
chef fief gueni Prigogine les hommes du
groupe Wagner se sont repliés
progressivement ils ont quitté la région
de vorogniège et la ville de Rostov sur
le don qu'ils ont occupé durant une
journée un retour au calme qui suscite
des réactions mitigées
nous n'avons pas besoin de Wagner ici à
Rostov
ils étaient des héros et maintenant je
ne sais pas elles ne sont plus personne
pour moi maintenant
comment j'interprète le fait qu'il soit
venu ici
les combattants de Wagner défendaient ce
qui est juste et c'est la bonne chose à
faire
lorsque quelque chose de routinier dans
votre ville change et que vous ne
comprenez pas vraiment ce qui se passe
vous vous sentez très anxieux en danger
je me sens donc soulagée
quelques heures plus tôt une foule
d'habitants était descendue dans les
rues pour acclamer le départ des
paramilitaires immortalisant l'instant
sur leur téléphone
une célébration qui tranche avec les
accusations de mutinerie portées par le
Kremlin à l'encontre du chef de Wagner
selon un habitant interrogé par France
24 de nombreux Russes ne savent plus
quoi croire après des années d'une
guerre qui se déroule juste de l'autre
côté de la frontière mais qu'ils n'ont
jamais vu de leurs yeux alors l'arrivée
de ces miliciens sont diffusion de son a
été vécue pour beaucoup comme un
spectacle
nous ne sommes que des gens ordinaires
plus rien ne nous fait peur ça fait
combien d'années que ça dure et on
entend toujours la même chose on ne peut
plus avoir peur de rien les gens veulent
jusque tout ça se termine et ça s'est
terminé proprement et pacifiquement
un retour au calme en Russie en trompe
l'oeil à Moscou comme dans sa région le
régime d'opérations antiterroriste qui
donne des pouvoirs accrus aux forces de
l'ordre étaient toujours en vigueur ce
dimanche